Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhodassam Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhodassam Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhodassam
Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-awakened one.
Yeah, it's funny, the microphones don't pick up singing so well, I don't know why.
Maybe it's my voice.
Okay, so this evening...
Nous allons regarder la façon dont le Bouddha parle du soi.
Et puis, bien sûr, il parle aussi du non-soi.
Donc, c'est un peu confus, je pense.
Quand vous commencez à traverser le bouddhisme, vous avez toujours ces trois caractéristiques, vous savez, la souffrance, l'impermanence et le non-soi.
Et tout le monde dit « Quoi ?
Non-soi ?
»
Quand on rencontre le bouddhisme, on entend toujours parler de ces trois caractéristiques, donc l'impermanence, la satisfaction et le non-soi.
Qu'est-ce que c'est le non-soi ?
Même pendant le temps du Bouddha, beaucoup de gens étaient confus.
Même à l'époque du Bouddha, beaucoup de gens ne le comprenaient pas vraiment.
Donc les Jainas disaient qu'eux et les hindous croyaient en un soi.
Les matérialistes de l'époque ne croyaient pas en un soi éternel.
Les bouddhistes n'arrivaient pas à se décider.
C'était très confus.
Voyons donc la façon dont le Bouddha utilise le soi-même.
Donc, regardons un peu comment le Bouddha utilise le soi.
Et donc, l'une des façons les plus connues, c'est son discours à Ananda, son conseil à Ananda.
Sois une île de toi-même, sois ton propre refuge, n'aie aucun autre.
Laisse le Dharma être une île et un refuge pour toi, n'aie aucun autre.
Et puis, dans le Dhammapada, c'est plein de ce boulot de soi.
La gloire grandit pour une personne qui est énergique et compréhensible.
La gloire augmente pour une personne qui est en pleine conscience et énergique, qui est pure et consciente de ses actions, restreinte et vigilante et qui vit le dharma.
Il est vigilant, il pratique la restreinte et vit le dharma.
Il y en a un autre ici.
Plus grand dans le combat que quelqu'un qui conquiert mille fois mille personnes.
plus grand dans le combat qu'une personne qui conquiert mille personnes, mille fois, est une personne qui se conquiert elle-même.
Et je vais juste prendre un ou deux autres.
« By oneself, evil is done.
By oneself alone, evil is done.
»
C'est soi-même, seul, qui fait le mal.
C'est né de soi-même et produit par soi-même.
Cela use ceux qui n'ont pas de sagesse comme un diamant
peut user un joyau.
Ce sont tous des vers du Dhammapada.
C'est à toi de faire un effort.
Les Tathagatas, c'est les Bouddhas, seulement vous disent comment.
Et les Tathagatas, les Bouddhas, nous disent simplement, seulement comment.
Tout est vert, en fait, par l'histoire dans le Dhammapada.
Et maintenant, il y a aussi un très célèbre, un bien connu,
Il y a aussi des vers très connus qui parlent du karma.
Je suis propriétaire de mon karma.
J'hérite de mon karma.
Je suis né de mon karma.
Je suis en relation avec mon karma.
Et je suis, ou j'existe, soutenue par mon karma.
« De cela, je serai l'air » « De cela, je serai l'air » Donc le Bouddha ne dénonce pas
Donc le Bouddha ne renie pas que nous avons un sens du soi.
Et il nous dit en fait de l'utiliser d'une bonne façon.
Donc, si nous regardons l'origination interdépendante, nous verrons que ce sens du soi, en fait, son origine est à un moment particulier.
Les quatre maillons du milieu représentent le processus par lequel nous connaissons quelque chose.
Tout ce dont nous avons l'expérience commence par un point de contact avec une des bases des sens.
Par exemple, il doit y avoir un son, une vibration,
qui arrive à mon oreille avant que je puisse entendre quelque chose.
C'est vrai pour les cinq sens physiques, mais c'est aussi vrai pour l'esprit-cœur.
L'esprit est aussi vu comme étant une base d'essence dans laquelle l'Eglise close se manifeste.
Donc, de cette première petite perception,
de cette petite première perception se manifeste quelque chose qui est perçu alors comme étant soit agréable ou pas agréable.
Donc le premier pas nous le traduisons comme contact et le second comme sensation ressentie.
Une chose qui n'est pas très claire dans la projection co-conditionnée, c'est qu'avec le contact et la sensation,
il y a aussi une perception qui se manifeste.
Dans la psychologie bouddhiste, la sensation et la perception se manifestent simultanément.
Et nous pouvons regarder une perception comme une photocopie.
Et on peut penser à une perception comme une photocopie.
Et cette photocopie change à chaque fois que nous avons une perception qui est similaire.
Et c'est ce que nous appelons normalement un concept.
La prochaine étape, c'est la réaction normale qui est vouloir ou ne pas vouloir, aimer ou ne pas aimer.
C'est seulement après cela que le sens ou la vue du soi apparaît.
Donc il y a eu un processus de perception, de ressentiment, de contact, de réaction, et c'est seulement après cela que le sens du soi, de moi, de moi faire quelque chose,
ou « je veux quelque chose » apparaît.
Et donc, il y a eu tout un processus de contact, de sensation, de perception, de réaction, avant que ce sens du soi ne se manifeste.
Et c'est à ce qu'il se manifeste.
Oui.
Et la façon normale de le traduire en anglais, c'est « craving », ce qui n'a pas besoin d'être si fort.
Et donc, en anglais, c'est traduit par le mot craving.
Et en français, on utilise normalement la soif.
C'est un désir très, très fort.
Et une fois qu'on en est arrivé là, c'est très difficile de ne pas passer à la prochaine étape.
La prochaine étape, c'est l'acte de volonté, le désir, et c'est pour cela que nous regardons la volonté et le désir.
Au point de devenir, c'est le point d'action, c'est le point de karma.
Et une fois que nous avons fait cela, nous ne pouvons pas arrêter les conséquences.
Et une fois que nous en sommes arrivés là, nous ne pouvons plus arrêter les conséquences.
Donc le sens du soi
fait partie de notre psychologie et le Bouddha l'accepte entièrement.
Maintenant, l'idée est que, une fois que nous avons un sens de soi, nous pouvons prendre le contrôle de nos vies et reconnaître que nous pouvons nous changer.
L'idée est qu'une fois que nous avons un sens du soi, nous pouvons prendre un contrôle sur la vie et aussi nous changer.
Nous pouvons voir que le sens du soi est, devons-nous dire, une tactique.
Si nous regardons le soi comme une tactique pour nous changer envers
Et donc on peut penser au soi comme étant une espèce de tactique pour changer notre comportement moral pour qu'il nous amène vers la libération.
On peut dire que l'enseignement du Bouddha ne concerne que deux choses, la transcendance et aussi l'éthique, la moralité.
Et il y a une connexion entre les deux.
Et avant de regarder, de parler plus de cette connexion, il y a un sutta, un très beau sutta, avec quelqu'un qui s'appelait Vachagotha.
Donc le sutta commence, la sette, Vāca-gauta ou Vāca-gauta,
se rendit devant le Bouddha et lui paya hommage.
Après avoir échangé les paroles de bienvenue et de plaisance, il s'assit sur le côté.
Et assis là, il demanda au béni, « Now then, venerable Gautama, is there a self ?
» « Dites-moi, venerable Gautama, est-ce qu'il y a un soi ?
» « When this was said, the Buddha, the Blessed One, was silent.
»
Et suite à cette question, le Bouddha resta sans parole.
Puis Vachagotha demanda, est-ce qu'il n'y a pas de soi ?
Et pour une deuxième fois, le béni resta silencieux.
Et donc, Vachagotha se leva et partit.
Et suite à cela, le Vénérable Ananda demanda au béni, « Pourquoi tu n'as pas répondu ?
»
Pourquoi ne vous n'y avez pas répondu ?
Le Bouddha répondit
Ananda, si j'avais dit à Macha Gauta que le soi existe, j'aurais pris le parti des bramines et des ascètes qui suivent la philosophie de l'éternalisme.
Si j'ai répondu qu'il n'y avait pas de soi,
Cela correspondrait aux Brahmins et aux contemplateurs qui sont des exponents de l'annihilation.
Donc ici, nous avons le Bouddha
ne pas vouloir tomber dans une vue sur ce qui est transcendant.
Ah !
Qu'il y ait un transcendant, il n'y a pas de déni.
Il y a quelque chose qu'il y a de transcendant, ça c'est vrai.
Mais il ne veut pas le substancier par une chose, comme une âme.
Maintenant, quand il s'agit de Vachagotha, il dit
Si je devais répondre qu'il n'y avait pas de soi, ça serait...
Désolé, quand il s'agit de Vachagotha, en demandant s'il y avait un soi, si je devais répondre qu'il y avait un soi... Attends, non, je lis le mauvais mot.
Essaye de nouveau, arrête.
Il dit...
C'est un passage long.
Si j'avais répondu à Vachagotha quand il m'a demandé s'il n'y a pas de soi, que c'était correct ?
Il aurait été vraiment confus et il se serait dit mais le soi que je pensais que j'avais n'existe plus.
On peut voir que cet enseignement n'était pas évident.
Donc, c'est clair que le Bouddha, en fait, parle de deux sois différents.
Donc, le soi conventionnel, le soi que
Nous pensons être, il ne le dénie pas.
Ce qu'il dit, c'est qu'en fait, il est impermanent.
Il se manifeste et il disparaît, comme toute chose.
Et il dit encore qu'on devrait utiliser ce sens du soi pour nous guider sur le chemin spirituel.
Comment est-ce qu'il explique ou est-ce qu'il démontre ce qui est transcendant ?
Un des vers les plus connus sur ce sujet dit
Il y a ce qui est non né, ce qui est inconditionné.
Not created ?
Incréé.
And not become.
How do you say that ?
Not become.
Qui n'est pas venu.
C'est très bien.
Yeah.
Now, the word he uses there...
Le mot Pali qu'il utilise dans ce cas, c'est « ati ».
L'autre mot Pali qui veut dire « être », c'est « oti ».
En Pali, quand on utilise le mot hoti, c'est un mot qui connecte les choses.
Donc on dit « ceci est un ordinateur ».
Mais le mot « ati » veut dire que cela existe, que cela existe vraiment.
Et puis il continue à dire que si cela n'existait pas, il n'y aurait pas d'escapement de se réélever, de se réélever, de se conditionner, etc.
Et donc, le texte continue.
Si cela n'existait pas, il n'y aurait pas d'échappatoire de ce qui est né, conditionné, et ainsi de suite.
Il y a un autre passage qui fait même plus clair qu'il y a une transcendance.
Il y a un autre passage qui est aussi clair, qui vient de ce qui est transcendant.
Il dit qu'il existe une dimension où les bases des sens
Tout ce dont nous avons l'expérience doit passer par les six sens.
Donc il y a aussi une expérience qui n'inclut pas les six sens.
Et puis il dit qu'il n'y a pas de lune, pas de soleil, même pas de temps.
Il n'y a pas de temps.
On ne vient pas, on ne part pas et on ne reste pas immobile.
Et l'exemple dernier qui me vient à la tête, c'est quand quelqu'un lui demande « Où est-ce que les quatre éléments sont détruits ?
»
Et ce qui est intéressant, c'est quand on lui demande où est-ce que les quatre éléments sont détruits.
Les quatre éléments, cela veut dire le monde physique.
qui lui dit qu'il ne connaît pas, mais que les meilleurs dieux sauront.
C'est Kevada.
Et donc le roi Kevada va voir les devas les plus hauts pour leur demander la question, aussi dans un texte, et ils répondent qu'ils ne savent pas,
mais que les dieux les plus hauts, les supérieurs, pourront lui répondre à cette question.
Et donc, il va voir les dieux qui sont supérieurs et lui disent la même chose.
Mais ceux qui sont plus raffinés même que nous pourront répondre à cette question.
Et de cette façon, il va de plus en plus haut dans les ciels, jusqu'à ce qu'il arrive au niveau le plus haut du paradis.
Le plus puissant.
Et les plus puissants.
Et puis là, les devas de ce paradis le plus élevé lui disent « Nous, nous ne savons pas non plus, mais le dieu Brahma pourra mourir.
»
dans un éclair Brahma se manifeste et Brahma dit je suis Brahma je suis le créateur je suis le plus grand je suis le plus puissant le créateur de tout et Kevata lui dit j'ai une question pour vous
Où cessent les quatre grands éléments ?
Et Brahma répond simplement, je suis Brahma, je suis le plus puissant, le plus grand, le créateur de tout.
Et Kevada dit « Je ne vous ai pas demandé qui vous étiez, qui vous étiez ou ce que vous étiez.
Je veux savoir où sont les quatre éléments qui arrivent à un fin.
» Et Kivata lui a répondu « Je ne vous ai pas demandé qui vous êtes, mais je voudrais savoir où les quatre éléments cessent.
»
Mais donc Brahma répond la même chose.
Et puis, la troisième fois, il prend le moine sur le côté pour lui parler en privé.
Il me dit, écoute, moi je ne sais pas, mais je n'ai pas envie que tous les autres...
Dieu, les débats, le sache.
Le Brahma dit au moine, celui qui peut répondre à cette question, c'est en fait le Bhagavad, le Bouddha.
Alors retourne le voir et pose-lui une question.
Les discours sont pleins de ce genre d'humour où le Bouddha se moque un peu
de la religion brahmanique et il fait la même chose quand il parle des castes.
Et donc Kevada va voir le Bouddha et le Bouddha en fait
rajoute quelque chose à la question ?
Où est-ce que les quatre éléments ?
Où est-ce que les Saintes Tandas, le corps-esprit, ne peuvent pas se poser ?
Il ne trouve pas d'endroit où se poser, où être.
Puis il dit qu'il y a un conscient qui n'est pas touché par les sens.
Il n'a pas de limites.
Cette conscience est pleine de lumière dans toutes les directions.
Et donc ici nous avons le Bouddha qui essaye d'exprimer, en utilisant les mots de son époque, quelque chose qui n'existait pas à son époque.
C'est de la même façon que Freud a dû inventer des nouveaux mots comme ego, id et superego pour expliquer sa vision.
Donc cette conscience n'est pas la même que la conscience ordinaire.
Elle ne peut pas l'être puisqu'elle ne se manifeste pas et elle ne disparaît pas.
Et j'aime utiliser le mythe de Narcissus.
Alors, comment est-ce qu'on peut le comprendre ?
Moi, j'aime utiliser le mythe de Narcissus pour l'expliquer.
Donc, l'histoire de Narcissus, il regarde dans un étang, dans une loupe,
Et il voit sa réflexion et il tombe amoureux de lui-même.
Et il est tellement amoureux, tellement pris par cette image, qu'il se penche pour l'embrasser, et il tombe dans l'étang et se noie.
Maintenant, dans la mythologie, l'eau est ce qui est créé.
Donc, ici nous avons...
Et donc, ce dont nous avons l'expérience en nous, c'est quelque chose qui observe et qui ressent.
et qui a ce sens du soi, cette réflexion de lui-même.
Quand nous méditons, nous tournons toutes nos expériences
Et quand nous faisons ça, nous avons un sens très puissant de
d'être celui qui observe, celui qui fait l'investigation, celui qui ressent.
Est-ce que c'est juste ?
Est-ce que c'est comme ça que vous le sentez ?
Donc, ce sens du soi, c'est Narcisse qui est en train de regarder dans les temps et qui perçoit son image comme dans un miroir.
C'est enchanté par ce qu'il voit dans l'esprit, dans le cœur, dans le corps-esprit-cœur.
Et donc, cette très grande compréhension dive dans le monde créé
Et donc, cette attention, cette pleine conscience se plonge dans le monde créé de cet organisme.
Il y a une connexion avec le monde que l'on voit.
Et donc, tout commence avec une délision.
Cette conscience, cette connaissance.
Je suis désolée, mais vous devez dire cette phrase en deux morceaux.
Ok, je ne me souviens plus jamais de ce que j'ai dit.
Juste un instant, juste un instant.
L'awareness, je préfère utiliser l'awareness, je ne sais pas, qu'est-ce que le mot français pour l'awareness ?
Eh bien, ça peut être attention, mais est-ce que c'est vraiment...
C'est plus comme la conscience, n'est-ce pas ?
Mais ce n'est pas vrai.
Et donc, ce qui sait s'expérience lui-même,
sur l'écran de la conscience, ce qui correspond à la surface de l'étang.
Et il est enchanté par ce qu'il voit, et donc est plongé dans le monde qui est créé par cet organisme.
Cet organisme, donc, ceci.
Donc, ça se passe dans votre méditation, quand vous observez, par exemple, une chance, une fatigue,
un sentiment très beau dans votre cœur.
Et donc ici, on a un conscient, une attention qui
qui ressent, qui se ressent elle-même.
Et puis... Désolée, j'ai perdu ça encore une fois.
D'accord.
Donc, ici nous avons l'awareness qui est consciente de soi-même sur l'écran de l'esprit, sa conscience, son écran,
Donc ici, nous avons une attention, une conscience qui est consciente d'elle-même sur l'écran du conscient.
Il n'y a pas beaucoup de mots en français, je ne sais pas très clair.
Ok.
Et sur ce écran, on voit aussi
Ce qu'est l'organisme, c'est qu'il ressent aussi le sens de joie qui est dans le cœur.
Et donc, sur cet écran, il ressent aussi l'éloignement qui est dans le cœur.
Quand on parlait d'angélisation, on ressent une joie dans le cœur.
Et donc, presque immédiatement, cette joie se transporte dans l'imagination et l'intellect et crée une fantaisie.
Et cette conscience devient la fantaisie.
Elle s'identifie complètement avec la fantaisie.
Et c'est le point de la délusion.
Donc, le processus de l'awakening
C'est donc la voie de la libération, c'est toujours de nous mettre, de nous reculer, de nous arracher de l'étang
et de nous asseoir sur le bord et d'observer et de voir la création.
Et en faisant cela, l'attention devient consciente de sa propre qualité.
C'est à ce moment-là que nous allons voir qu'il existe le non-né, le non-créé, le non-conditionné.
Et donc le dernier petit tour que l'on peut jouer sur nous-mêmes dans notre méditation.
Quand le corps est immobile, le cœur est tranquille et que l'esprit est très silencieux,
Il y a un sens très fort d'être celui qui observe, celui qui ressent, celui qui sait.
Juste à ce moment-là, si vous pouvez vous imaginer en regardant dans un mirage, et que vous pouvez voir votre visage dans le mirage,
Juste à ce moment, si vous imaginez que vous regardez dans un miroir, et que vous pouvez voir votre visage dans le miroir.
Et donc, vous pouvez...
Regardez vers l'arrière, si on veut.
Regardez vers la tension elle-même.
Et après avoir regardé, demandez qu'est-ce qui était là ?
Qu'est-ce que vous avez vu ?
Quelle était l'expérience ?
J'espère que ces pensées m'ont donné un mal de tête.
J'espère que mes mots vont pouvoir vous aider.
Mais je n'ai pas causé trop de confusion.
Et que par votre dévotion à la pratique, vous allez réaliser votre vraie conscience.
Le bouddha intérieur.
Tuna, rather than later.
Plutôt que tard.